what do you do last minute
when an outfit does not fit and you have to wear it out tomorrow
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna adapt
um so my friend phaith is partnering with PLT and designed this outfit very
very cute my fat ass doesn't really fit in it because there's no stretch
and I'm like
on the border of like
a 26 28
and PLT goes up to 26 you see
so there's no stretch doesn't usually work
um my fault
my bad so here's the thing
this top if I had
if I had to go out in this
like I can make it work
um only problem is like
I feel as though if I breathe wrong
this is it's coming out
you know what I mean so here's the option
and also this is not the way that this top is supposed to be wear like this
this is not a strap it's supposed to go like
right here but uh
that's just is um
this that wouldn't work
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna adapt
and we're gonna scrap the top
I'm just like sorry love
you can't wear it
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna put on this set from Pretty Little Thing
which is like
one of the most iconic sets right
I'm gonna use a skirt as a top
and I'm gonna pair with these two things
that's the vibe in case you're curious
this is this is kind of how the
this this is what I put around my neck
um and I kind of ripped it
but like
this like
is a very precarious situation that I'm in right now
and if I let go or if I literally bent down the wrong way
this would open so that's why I was putting it around
if I had to wear it like that
I would but this top is like
it's not it's not
it wouldn't do you see what I'm saying
it wouldn't work um
so I'm gonna wear the skirt as a top
cool
so I figured out this is this is kind of the vibe I'm going with now
this is a pretty little thing set um
and im just wearing the skirt as a top ha ha
i’m wearing the skirt as the top my friends over there
um so this is it
this is what I'm gonna wear tomorrow
and I think it looks good